the shock of this shooting has brought
an outpouring of sympathy from all
around the world many cities across the
u.s. held vigils last night to honor the
59 people who died Adriana Diaz is here
in Las Vegas with the story of one of
those victims and the woman who stayed
with him until the end
Adriana good morning good morning we're
at a growing memorial for the wounded
and for the dead one of those was Jordan
McGill dude just 23 years old
he lived in Canada and worked in
construction according to his Facebook
page and he spent his final minutes with
a complete stranger who never left his
side it's what you see on TV and it's
never going to you it's never going to
happen to you it was Heather goos was
working as a bartender at the concert
and escaped the gunfire but 23 year-old
concert goer Jordan McGill Doon did not
he was among the seriously wounded
Heather helped his fingers were kind of
wrapped on my hand his hand like kind of
squeezed a little bit and then just like
wet loose Heather spoke to Jordan's
girlfriend using his cell phone she was
sheltering in place nearby
she said I'm be honest with me like
what's going on you know he didn't make
it she said to me you know he's the love
of my life like are you sure there were
dozens of stories like Jordans Sunday
night people with little in common
except for being caught in the
crosshairs of a killer Sandi Melton of
Tennessee reportedly was running with
his wife to safety when he was shot and
killed our whole town is [ __ ] turned
upside down
Charleston Hartfield was a 34 year olds
Las Vegas police officer off duty at the
time of the shooting Angela Gomez was a
cheerleader from California
Rachel Parker worked for the police
department in Manhattan Beach California
teacher sandy Casey was remembered by
her partner as a woman who quote lived
life to the fullest
and made me the happiest man in the
world I'm connected to him now my life
heather stayed with Jordans body for
more than four hours we didn't want him
to get lost no I would hope somebody
would do it for me I would hope that
they wouldn't let me be alone Heather
says she is not a hero that the heroes
are the people who rushed in to save
lives and while she may not have been
able to save a life she did save a
family from the agony of waiting hours
to find out the fate of their loved one
Nora that is so true Adrianna what is
story and there are so many more stories
like that to be told